jose quintana in his career gooby
has been strong against the dodgers look
you need some positive numbers it's been
a tough year for him
he's handled lefty so far this year and
he's dealing one with
corey seeger right now there it is i
mean that's a completely different pitch
that one just died in home plate sony
the top of the first inning but when
trevor bauer is on the mound how well
he's thrown this is a huge
part of the game for 10 and the angels
with taylor and his success against him
five for 11.
pitch number 30 is lifting into left
field here comes justin upton and he
runs it down
good first year going with the dodgers
for trevor bauer who has a 244 era
that's retired there's two gone jared
walsh coming up
now the 3-2 ball strike three
fastball at the knees outside corner and
that
is that upton hit a home run on friday
night
as a home run against bauer in his
career
upton leading off this inning taking
strike three on a fastball
second straight strikeout for bauer jose
rojas
his first big league home run last night
10 pitch
gets rojas with the change-up which he
threw
four times against the cubs on tuesday
he had only thrown four of them all year
before that
it's nasty two on two out
and chris taylor coming up two one
taylor hits it to center field that'll
dunk in for a base hit in front of trout
turn her head at home the throws cut off
and taylor delivers with two gone to
give the dodgers the one-nothing lead
oh you said he lined out to left milky
lined out to right nobody had tried
center yet
he did the dodgers have the game's first
run
trevor bauer working two outs bases
loaded this is a big at bat in the game
for the angels and
derrick walsh
what a swing by walsh and it's a 2-1
angels lead they get to trevor bauer
dj peters goes to work
fastball blazed over the plate strike
three
lock them up pets is already batting for
the third time in the game we're only in
the fourth inning
just what the doctor ordered and a pump
of the fist
will smith he's back in there he's gone
over for two
pop out strikeout for him today
the 3-2 popped up
late break because of that sunshine a
very late break
that's a good play by taylor ward he was
under control even though he had to go a
long long way to get to that
keep in mind he was a first round pick
as a catcher
he's bounced around at a number of
different positions including going back
and catching in spring
going wall way dealing with the sun
sliding in nice defensive play
on a jared walsh double in the third
inning angels ahead of bauer in the
dodgers 2-1 we go to the bottom of the
fifth
nine one and two coming up just to find
a lot of holes
foul tipped into the glove strike three
will smith knew it home plate umpire
troop gibson agreed
bauer has his sixth k
here's his 02. threw it again and struck
him
one two three fifth for bauer on 11
pitches
so mookie bits the battery's over two of
the walk today
size this match up up for me right now
you have a lefty against the dangerous
right-handed hitter you got to try to
get him to
expand the strike zone the 1-2
rolls over something soft doubled up on
across the diamond he did not straighten
it out
he trevor stayed to mike trout with a
3-2
he struck him out with a fastball eighth
strikeout of the game for bauer one gone
in the six
quite a battle whole bunch of cutters
and then
the four seamer
look like they were attacking trout at
the top of the strike zone for the hole
at bat
struck out trout now fires a 1-2 and
strikes out walsh
got him looking with the fastball his
fourth k in a row his ninth of the day
2-2 from bauer ground ball left side
knocked down to the backhand by lutz
recovers and throws him out
trevor bauer throws 113 pitches
mike myers in this 2-1 game takes the
opportunity the ohio native to go to
work
he managed to strike out there he got
him to take the bat off his shoulders
whatever myers throws engaged the
patient muncie when you go back to last
season how good he was against lefties
he stayed in there with that cut
fastball throughout that entire at-bat
muncie unable to bring his hands up and
make contact three times
he went outside corner fastball throws
him i think he was looking
in that's a straight four seamer so
often you see that for hitter in a bat
you're up there especially in a pinch
hit roll you had a pitch to hit
and you missed it and then you're
thinking
i missed my pitch where's he throwing it
and before you do that you got to deal
with a fastball
paint got him
three outs to get dodgers will bring
that infield in
on the grass can't be comfortable
feeling for him with trout at the plate
fletcher third one gone two one game
last of the eight
jansen to trout with a 2-2 pitch
struck him out
big time k for kenley janssen trout is
out number two
second and third two gone a 2-2 pitch
he's working kenley janssen puts up a
zero in the eighth
can the offense find some magic in the
ninth
reisel iglesias when the chips have been
down
is when he has been the most effective
in save situations
it's been eating innings and different
situations
that's when he has had some struggles
this year the veteran right-hander at 31
years old goes to work with an electric
arm looking to claim this series for the
halos
angels are one out away from taking two
out of three against the dodgers here in
the opening round of the freeway
series
[Applause]
bouncing ball out toward third to the
bag the freeway
series this one belongs to the angels
they take two of three from the los
angeles dodgers round number one goes to
the men in red
in orange county and the halo will shine
bright tonight